you just got in from israel is that
right that is correct you were in israel
what were you doing in israel i was the
ambassador of gay pride for israel oh
congratulations
very good
i learned a lot while i was there what
did you what did you what can you tell
us i've not been to israel what can you
tell me about it well it's a bucket list
thing for me i've always wanted to go
but i've definitely learned a lot the
first thing i learned was there are
apparently no ugly women whatsoever in
israel
i have heard the women are
extraordinarily unbelievable eat at one
would walk in the room and you'd think
she's hot the next one and walk in the
room was like screw the other one and
each one i'm i'm emigrating yeah you're
coming i am grating you're going i'm
done i'm going change faith and i still
can't figure out how to happen because i
saw plenty of ugly men yeah really
so where did the pretty women come you
know i don't know i don't know because
the catholic school they taught me that
men were involved
that's the first thing they tell you in
catholic school that's a that's a joke
they didn't teach sex exactly catholic
school i know
they really i actually they really
didn't uh this was my sex education
class in catholic school they sat me
down and none sat down next in front of
the class and said if you should ever
slow dance with a boy make sure there's
enough room between you to throw a cat
you throw a cat
no okay i'm curious about something
you've obviously gotten very famous from
the show do you get approached a lot for
photographs you must constantly have
people bothering because you're very
recognizable you know some people can
blend in but you can't blend in i can
i'm a little unforgettable you're right
some of the like the women on our show
are absolutely stunningly beautiful all
of them right and then there's me right
and uh no no no i'm saying you have a
very distinct
exactly they can all walk around nobody
nobody andrew
they can walk around
nobody bothers them but i look exactly
like me so it's just non-stop and what's
really great is they see you and
immediately there's huge smile on their
face
my fiance says she calls me bulldike
santa claus
yes the side of me makes people happy
now you this is very hard for me to
believe but you were an openly gay
comedian for 10 years
before you came out to your family
right
not true before i came out to my parents
let's be clear okay my parents all right
still did you i mean first of all your
parents did they did they have an
inkling
okay let me put it this way
my yeah my siblings and my mom just gave
me nothing but attitude oh really you're
a lesbian what are you gonna do now play
softball you know like that kind of
stuff yeah
but
my father had no clue your father had no
idea look at me
knock at me he had no
no clue none i mean
i'm on every day of my life look at me
every day
somebody calls me sir yeah
every day of my life the worst is in the
gynecologist's office
[Applause]